[Music]
a moment in history
and a natural chance to have a proper
conversation about the future of our
monarchy royalty is a feudal thing and
it needs to be abolished King Charles is
important to us there's nothing that
they do that really impacts my life it
doesn't matter who he is it's the fact
we have a monarchy I'm traveling from
the silly Isles I don't think we should
take him down or anything but you're not
called a revolution
to Scotland it's much more an English
thing than as a Scottish thing I'd
rather have him than some presidential
guy to find out what people in this
country think of its king
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
spanking UK
but alongside the adoring crowds A
Chorus of opposition
these aren't random protesters or
disgruntled citizens of York instead
they're from Auntie monarchy campaign
group Republic
and their CEO Graham Smith has been on
this path for decades
his life's mission to abolish the
monarchy and Usher in the age of Britain
as a parliamentary Republic
well I've always been opposed to the
monarchy I remember I was 12 years old
the year that Andrew and Sarah Ferguson
got married and I objected to the idea
of having to sit in the classroom and
watch the wedding and as I got older it
just made more sense that this is you
know not appropriate in the Democratic
Society Charles needs to pay isn't time
he needs to stop protecting his brother
a republic is about making Britain
govern better by having a an accountable
independent head of state
[Applause]
monarchy is about saying you're a
Spectators you stand over there wave at
us
and being a republic is about being
participants saying actually we're not
going to have a coronation we're not an
election we're not going to have a
child's we want a choice
expectations
of Camp down here know that King Charles
is inside York Minster and I have to
suspect that Republic will be pretty
pleased with the protest of hand today
but if you compare the numbers those who
are protesting and those who disagreed
with the protest like republicanism has
gone awfully long way to go
I am loving your crown and I take it
you've come here to see Charles today
yes so what do you think of the man I
think he's doing a good job it doesn't
matter who he is it's the fact that we
have a monarchy there's a group over
there called Republic yeah
yeah and then it's part of our heritage
and our history and I think they're King
yeah if you
yeah he's the
he's been chosen to be
perfect I don't like football so I don't
go
well I'm ashamed of them they need to
why why come why come if they want to I
know that they're making a noise and
freedom of speech but go home it is like
this it does strike me that perhaps this
is a bit of a tough quote for you yeah I
mean you know the crowd that we're we're
looking to reach is the much wider crowd
of you know the people that are going to
see this on TV and see in the papers so
obviously people that come down here in
the middle of a weekday to wave a flag
in the chair of the king they're not our
co-orderlands
Wisconsin
is bubble it's difficult to get a deeper
sense of Charles the man so I popped
drones to see Kathy let a proper Aussie
living in London and a confidante of
both king and queen from any
g'day and you've dressed appropriately
I'm feeling the animal magnetism already
thank you get in here
Kathy first things first you are friends
with the Royals but but describe
yourself as a republican square that
Circle for me
well you take people as you find them
and you know Prince Charles princes are
supposed to be charming and he is
charming and also I think he was so
prescient I mean he was way ahead of his
time on all those environmental issues
which I can connect with him on that be
time so you know you you can't help
liking them I would say Charles's charm
is more disarming than a un peacekeeping
Force really and and also Camilla she
treats everyone the same from maid to
Monarch but you know most English people
you have to do open heart surgery to
know what's going on inside them right
facial expressions by Taxidermy you know
their voices are so brittle it's like
they've got
osteoporosis there's vocal osteoporosis
but he's not like that he's he's
different and I think the public will
absolutely come to see that side of him
and and love it
foreign
the coronation stage is set and love
them or loathe him it is pretty obvious
that the king approaches the big day
with something of an image problem
he comes to the throne in the midst of a
cost of living crisis that casts a long
Shadow over the opulence of a coronation
and the Royal lifestyle of policies and
pageantry but much closer to the king is
the ongoing Scandal involving his
brother Andrew Harry are you putting
money before family and of course the
immediate family feud
Harry and Megan's decision to leave the
royal family and the country is explored
in that book that the house of Windsor
so plagued by whiteness said goodbye to
its first mixed race member is clearly
not a good look but is there a way back
I think the first thing to say is hands
up whose family isn't slightly
dysfunctional the difference is that
there's it's played out 24 7 for
everyone to see
would I like to see Harry and Megan uh
back in the Royal fold 100 percent
the prospect of this family being center
stage with the King
unlocks so many opportunities
for a Multicultural Society I just hope
it works for them on a personal level
but for our nation I think it's a
win-win
[Music]
Birmingham is one of the UK's most
diverse cities with ethnic minorities
making up more than half the population
and that's something reflected in the
student body at Birmingham City
University
what does the royal family mean to you
if anything they don't really hold any
relevance to me at the end of the day
because I don't see anybody that's like
me
um at the end of the day there's nothing
that they do that's really impacts my
life given the things that happen with
um Meghan Markle coming into the royal
family I think it just kind of shows
that the Divide is
very much real and
that kind of like traditional
um
family life that the Royals do have is
not inclusive
the university is home to the first
black studies course in the UK its
founder candy Andrews sees the royal
family as Beyond repair and they are the
head of state right and this is the
state that treats us like subjects it
does not treat us like citizens we just
had the windrow Scandal where people
have been deported you can see pretty
much every inequality from education
policing prisons health is this is not a
good country to grow up in if you're
black and the head of state represents
that it is entirely
unreasonable to justify this almost
exclusively white family and being the
representative not just of Britain but
of 14 other countries largely back in
brown of the Commonwealth what that does
psychically what that does emotionally
is to put whiteness on a pedestal that's
the rule so if you're serious about it
you have to say look we have to abandon
this rule Charles has suggested is that
the archives be opened up that the Royal
Family do start to be somewhat more open
about their links to slavery you scoff
there I do it I take it you don't think
too much of that I mean that's the
absolute bare minimum opening up the
archives in the 21st century for a start
we actually know quite a lot already
about the royal families our involvement
in slavery and a proper account would be
if he's actually serious he'd say well
actually let's try and account for how
much money in reparation we need to pay
for the monarchy these are uncomfortable
conversations but we have to be big
enough to say this is our history and
it's not just their history it's a
history that has built the present
and if that is built on great inequity
great inequality
that continues
then you have to start a conversation
that says how do we mitigate that
how do we begin to get it right
as King Charles navigates issues with
race he and his family also find
themselves under the microscope when it
comes to money
they receive around 86 million pounds a
year from the taxpayer
and they have a whole host of other
assets around the country
for over half a century Charles was the
Duke of Cornwall and owner of the duchy
of Cornwall estate
this privately held land spans 50 000
hectares
it brings in millions of pounds every
year of what the Royals describe as
their private income Prince William has
now inherited the title the estate and
all of its money
[Music]
but you don't have to look far to see
his father's imprint and Legacy on these
lands
[Music]
next door to Newquay is Nan's letter
this brand new town sits on Dutchy land
and was dreamed up and developed by
Charles
[Music]
in a very real sense this place is a
physical manifestation of Charles ideas
his philosophies his environmentalisms
made not flesh but brick and stone so
I'm going to speak to a couple of the
people that live here to find out what
they make of it
I absolutely love it love living here
what we've got here is a Vibrant
Community there's lots of things going
on clearly you don't have to be a
loyalist you don't have to be a
monarchist to deliver in this part of
the world but but I wonder how you how
you perhaps think of Charles given you
know that this was a big project for him
it has been something that he and the
duchy have been pushing for for a very
long time well I've met him twice he's
interested in how his infrastructure is
actually coming to life and and what
people think about that he's very
passionate about that this place will be
around in 50 years time clearly I'm
gonna be cheeky right now and ask you do
you think the monarchy will be
personally I'd like to see it continue
and that's what I look at more than
innocent I don't judge someone on the
fact that they wear a crown and judge
them on who they are as individuals so
hopefully I'd like to see it carry on
because they've done a lot
there's certainly a sense of affection
for the king in his homegrown town
and it's held up as a beacon of good
Royal investment
but I want to travel to the islands of
the very South Western tip of this
County and indeed the mainland
Mainland Penzance in fact and I've taken
the 20-minute flight 34 miles to the
Isles of Celly which I am reliably
informed are beautiful in pretty much
anywhere there but I'm also told that
there the view of the dutchie and of
Charles well it's a bit next
silly has its own micro climates and I
have a delicate stomach
the fine storm isn't going to stop me
from getting over there to find out
who's got a guillotine to grind and why
[Music]
thank you the Isles of silly are made up
of 200 Islands although only five are
inhabited
[Music]
nearly all of the land here is owned and
released at by the duchy of Cornwall
[Music]
thank you
also owns a third of the properties here
[Music]
walking the streets of Saint Mary's
feels like taking a step back in time
appropriately enough given some here say
the way the duchy operates belongs in
the history books
[Applause]
Alan Davis who's lived on silly for 40
years is a republic member and fierce
critic of the duchy Cornwall
Alan hello Nia how are you doing nice to
see you
so if the duchy of Cornwall owns these
places and how much money are they
making at this part of the world oh well
on Grand Rental will you estimate they
take out close on a million pounds and
very little of that comes back into the
islands in terms of supporting the
islands so what then is your view
of what the duchy of Cornwall is doing
with these islands it's a cash cow
they're operating a feudal system
um and medieval fuel system and they're
just taking the cash out housing is a
big problem here over 200 properties
actually belong to the duchy they rent
them out which is fair enough but they
also rent out properties for Holiday
lets whereas we need teachers we need
care home assistance we need people to
operate in the hospital but it's not
just through leases that you know the
duchy is making its money it's making
its money off what every person
all afraid that comes on on over here
and also everybody who lands on the key
in there they pay a levy to the duchy
and I think that we've come to the point
where
um royalty or monarchy is a feudal thing
that needs to be abolished and the Dutch
you are actively working against that
they don't want to see it but abolished
because it'll cut their income
stronghold his views may be Alan
certainly isn't spokesman for these
islands
[Music]
foreign
ahead of the coordination just asking
everyone what their thoughts are about
chance about the royal family about the
coordination itself I mean are you going
to be celebrating it
um I'm not
at the same so I mean a lot of that is
important to them there's a lot of money
that goes into them that could be better
spent elsewhere King Charles is
important to us he's a real advocate for
the natural world and protecting
Wildlife I don't think they should hold
quite as huge of a place I don't think
we should take them down or anything but
um you're not calling for a revolution
um because I don't think they quite
serve the purpose they may be used to
the light Underground
welcome
to jackpot
[Music]
in response to the issues raised on the
silly Isles the duchy says it takes its
rule as stakeholder very seriously that
they play a key role in helping to
deliver sustainable development and
communities and have facilitated a wide
range of opportunities for housing and
business
I am just about to leave not by sea
thankfully and the thought occurs that
if you arrive by boat by ferry by
playing on or indeed by a helicopter you
will be paying money to the duchy of
Cornwall and you might be absolutely
fine with that but many people here
including Alan are not the reason being
that he and others think that Charles
viewed this place as his personal cash
card now things may very well change
know that he is King we'll just have to
wait and see
[Music]
thank you
the further you travel from the English
heartlands the more you'd expect support
for the monarchy to win and Scotland has
always been significantly Less in favor
of the royal family than the rest of the
country it's another thing I love about
this journey is that it does afford you
time to think I'm sure the queen is not
exactly the same way she must have made
this journey a hundred times traveling
from London to England then on to
Balmoral for our summer holidays as I'm
sitting here staring out of the window I
mean even close to me the queen famously
had a huge amount of affection for this
place I just wonder whether or not this
place has much affection for King
Charles
thank you I was four when we had the
queen I'm not anymore now we're doing
it's much more an English sling than I
just got
coach do you feel like he's your kid
nope
liked his mum
I don't know what you
I'd rather have him than some
presidential
elected guy
I want to hear and politicians
whilst the country has gained a new king
Scotland has gained a new first Minister
and itself feels at a turning point
politically and perhaps even
constitutional
before he became leader of the SNP Hamza
Yusuf spoke openly about his desire for
Scotland to ditch the royal family
another attempt at Independence would
offer republicanism a chance to ride on
its cocktails and unmissable opportunity
Tommy Shepard is an SNP MP his
constituency is home to Craig Miller
castle and irony given that he is a very
loud Republican voice explain to me make
the case if you can for getting rid of
them all okay you mean you're no big fan
are you no I'm not I mean I think it's a
relic of pycon days that has no place in
a modern democratic Constitution to be
honest the question is can we do better
I think we can have a head of state
which is elected the Monarch at the end
of the day is a is a a creature of the
government of the day and that's not a
healthy separation of Parish in any
constitutional Arrangement and that's
simply because you know they are
hereditary and no one's had a had a say
in choosing them the idea that the royal
family can persist for so many people in
in this part of the world does at least
suggest to me that it that it isn't
necessarily all about the Constitutional
Arrangement that it is about something
more ephemeral I get that there's a sort
of stability and certainty that comes
from the idea of the monarchy but you
know we need to see past that and people
I think increasingly understand it in
the modern ERA this really is a medieval
fairy story that ought to be left in the
history books
thank you
well there may be little chance of
Britain becoming a republic anytime soon
the anti-monarchist movement shows no
science of going quietly we're going to
be protesting out the coronation in
London
come down and join us here's the King
after all doesn't he deserve a
coordination most monarchies ditched
these things a long time ago Charles is
already the king it doesn't need this
this is a pointless parade designed for
him to sort of say you know look at me
I'm King
all eyes on the king come coordination d
but how Charles navigates the rule set a
tone and direction for the monarchy of
the future
[Music]
will he get it absolutely right I hope
so
is it a bit of a high wire act most
definitely
[Music]
I think if you care about your people
then you feel Duty bound to say this is
my role
in 21st century Britain
and if I seize it then I can do good
things even just for nostalgic reasons
you know like a museum piece you might
keep this this show rolling but then
again perhaps it'll become like a theme
park where you can you can pay to go and
and be be king for the day and sit on
the throne the cause for Colonial
Nostalgia is just as strong as it ever
were and that's the function of the
royal family so I actually think that
this place in society is very very well
set for the next 100 200 years as I've
traveled the country it has certainly
been a mixed bag of opinion but one
thing is certain like it or not this
coordination is going ahead what is
lesser however is whether or not we'll
see another one of this magnitude or
indeed whether we will see another
coordination at all
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]